voilà du temps de l'alliance j'étais
tout jeune j'en ai en classe alors ma
mère me faisait gavi c'était comme ça
qu'on gardait au ca prenaient les vestes
et oui une toutes les deux en reste et
vous faisait autant de connor que
maintenant ah non non non le faisait
nous avons deux canards jeux par an
c'est comme ça vous savez je sais pas
c'était pas pareil
c'était il ya très longtemps c'était en
celui-ci 722 plus vite c'est bien s'est
mis à ça
maintenant c'est adele la machine en
fait des machines électriques
je reviens
matin et soir on les gave ici il y en a
500 pour le fermier c'est la principale
source de revenus à côté juste un peu de
maïs pour garder les bêtes mais tout
faire un choix il faut travailler dur de
5 heures du matin à 9 heures du soir
jamais de repos jamais de vacances dans
les canards à quatre noix la torture
commencé à lui revint jours tout de
suite après on tue en plumes et c'est le
marché
un codage con et ça pèse combien de kg 5
kg 500 environ 5 à 6 kg 5 théo 500
celui-ci environ et quel est le prix est
quand même vous vendez un ca 11 50 ans
et 50 branche de 50 points mais à
l'intérieur et à la fois leur foie gras
à l'intérieur il doit faire 600 grammes
environ
oui en touchant ici oui au crayon ou et
vous rendre compte vous même avec le
doivent s en tire une partie molle et
une partie dure sa partie molle c'est le
foie elle a battu coeur c'est la grèce
oui
je la vends
voilà c'est vrai
il ya toujours à peu près les mêmes
acheteurs de la région sont des
conserveurs alors on s'est un peu près
on vend à peu près toujours au même mois
un vendeur je demande un prix je tente
d'accord où je tombe pas d'accord alors
à ce moment là viennent d'autres
acheteurs alors si je vois que mon prix
ne correspond pas je paie simple alors
où ça va où ça va pas alors en fin de
marché évidemment c'est très mauvais
parce que là il faut s'aider voulait
remporter il avait que vous pouvez vous
rendre si ça arrive ça arrive cet
avantage production jusque là artisanale
la consommation croissante du foie gras
implique aujourd'hui une étape
industrielle la conserve et ses
débouchés
alors qu'il ya quelques années les
producteurs gaver leurs joies et leurs
canards uniquement pour la production
perçoit par en trois mois et maintenant
il ya le toute l'année donc c'est
intéressant producteurs c'est
intéressant également pour l'industriel
qui peut faire travailler ses employés
toute l'année le plus difficile pour une
fois grâce à savoir les choisir
parce que si vous mettez du foie gras de
mauvaise qualité en boîte il est
difficile d'en sortir
mais une fois que vous avez bien choisi
votre fera sans unité sociale tous un
prénom de sa ville point près le faire
cuire le puy du fou gras de canard vaut
actuellement sur la qualité entre 60 et
65 francs mais c'est le très très
variable il ne connaissons pas les
fruits qui seront pratiqués la 15e jour
d'un jour et le prix actuel du foie
d'oie est de 8 à enjeu mais la cirrhose
du foie
ça se paye
[Musique]